With a mysterious new villain, a surprise
twist and big changes for all of our favourite
characters, the Witcher Season 2 has tons
of details we need to discuss.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining everything you might
have missed in the ending of Season 2 and
what it all means for Season 3.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
Key to understanding the Season 2 finale is
the Deathless Mother, aka Voleth Meir, a demon
who takes possession of Ciri.
According to Vesemir, the first witchers imprisoned
Voleth Meir in a hut long ago.
One of the oldest monsters.
A demon.
She wreaked havoc until the witchers bound
her deep in the forest.
However, the demon woke from her slumber after
Ciri's scream split the monolith outside Cintra.
She begins by appearing in the dreams of Yennefer,
Fringilla, and Queen of the Elves Francesca,
and manipulates their fears and personal pain.
For Yennefer, the demon taunts her about her
loss of power after Sodden Hill and promises
it back if she takes Ciri to the broken monolith
by Cintra.
For Fringilla, the Deathless Mother spurs
her on to take power for herself by forming
an alliance with the Elves.
This leads the Nilfgaardians to mistrust the
sorceress and when she uncovers their plot
and takes revenge, you can hear Voleth Meir
cackling in the background feeding off the
pain and destruction she's sown.
As for Francesca, the demon takes the form
of the legendary Elven prophet Ithlinne who
preys on her insecurity about never having
brought a baby to term and promises she'll
finally give birth to a pure Elven child.
However, when Francesca's baby is cruelly
assassinated, the Deathless Mother revels
in her suffering, which gives her the energy
to break free from her prison in the hut.
The newly-liberated demon seeks out Ciri,
possesses her, and begins to murder the witchers
at Kaer Morhen one-by-one.
Notice how she uses the same dagger that she
used to kill an early witcher.
Klef here was one of the first witchers.
That's what she used to kill him.
So, Voleth Meir is basically using the same
dagger to enact revenge on the school of witchers
who locked her away all those years ago.
Although Geralt arrives to try to break Ciri
out of the Deathless Mother's possession,
the demon is able to keep control of her by
offering her an alternate world in her mind
where she can be with loved ones she's lost.
And fans of Bly Manor will notice some interesting
parallels here with that horror story.
Voleth Meir then uses Ciri's scream to split
open the Witcher Medallion tree, revealing
a stone monolith which she splits into shards
that attack the witchers, before creating
a portal that pulls through a pair of basilisk
monsters from another world which she sets
upon the witchers.
In fact this moment was foreshadowed in the
fifth episode when Triss and Ciri journeyed
into the valley of Ciri's soul, and Ciri began
to call out to Geralt who was with Istredd
at the site of the shattered monolith outside
Cintra.
Geralt!
As Ciri called out, the Medallion Tree at
Kaer Morhen began to crack and vibrate, a
clue to the hidden stone inside, and shards
of the monolith outside Cintra flew into the
air and opened up a gateway that released
another monster.
Istredd who'd been researching monoliths discovered
that they were all connected and that on the
same day Ciri destroyed the first stone, another
monolith began to vibrate, something which
led to a new theory about what happened during
the Conjunction of Spheres, the event that
collided worlds together.
If the original spheres are still out there
somewhere and our monoliths are calling to
them…
then the monsters aren't new.
And they're using our monoliths as gateways.
Although the witchers manage to slay the basilisks,
the Deathless Mother remains firmly in control
of Ciri keeping her tucked away in the happy
memories of her long-dead family.
I'm staying right here.
Forever.
Geralt realises the only option is to find
an alternate vessel to Ciri to contain the
demon, which leads to Yen sacrificing herself
in a call-back to her attempted suicide in
Season 1, something also foreshadowed in her
vision with the Deathless Mother.
For Yennefer, this is the moment to right
the wrong she did to Ciri by almost delivering
her to Voleth Meir, and the spell she casts
pulls the demon out of Ciri and into her.
Notice how Yen's eyes finally become purple
again at this point because this is the moment
her magic returns after being depowered for
most of the second season.
I felt it come back when I…
When you sacrificed yourself for Ciri.
Next though, to get the monster out of Yennefer,
Ciri uses her own powers to take herself,
Geralt and Yen into another world.
As they all land on another sphere, the demon
leaves Yen and reforms itself as one of a
group of apocalyptic riders which fans of
The Witcher 3 game and the books will recognise
as The Wild Hunt.
The Wild Hunt is a group of antagonists who
are associated with being an omen of doom,
appearing before or during times of war, and
they were mentioned this way a couple of times
in Season 2.
The Wild Hunt walks among us!
They're known for travelling between realms
and kidnapping people to use as slaves and
they're clearly after Ciri specifically because
of her exceptional powers.
Child of the Elder Blood, starry-eyed Daughter
of Chaos, join our Hunt.
Your place is among us.
By the way, not only does the reddish colouring
of this world give it hellish, apocalyptic
feel, but it may also be an allusion to the
name "Red Riders" that the Wild Hunt are sometimes
known by.
The Wild Hunt also appeared during the journey
into Ciri's deep subconscious when she discovered
she's a descendant of Lara Dorren.
Notice the little blue flowers here around
the dying elf which only grow wherever Elder
Blood has been spilled, like the ones which
grew from Ciri's blood around Kaer Morhen.
Lara Dorren was an Elven sorceress who had
a child with a human mage;
however, their union was controversial among
both humans and elves, which led to Lara's
persecution.
When Istredd visits Codringher and Fenn, he
learns about the curse Lara placed before
she died
'My curse will hound your descendants unto
the tenth generation.'
'Until the columns of time and space tremble
and open for my people.'
'Then my vengeance will be born again.'
The curse alludes to Ciri's screams and her
effect on the monoliths which have now opened
portals in space-time that allow inter-dimensional
travel,
and it also ties in with Ithillinne's Prophecy
that predicts the end of the world, a part
of which Lara Dorren recites to Ciri during
her mind journey with Triss.
The world will die amidst frost and be reborn
of the new sun.
Reborn of Elder blood, of the seed that has
been sown.
A seed that will not sprout, but will burst
into flame.
Elder blood is a gene that tends to pass on
more in the female line, and although Calanthe
possessed it herself, the Queen tried to supress
knowledge of her Elven heritage.
And Ciri witnesses that fear herself when
she sees her mother and father arguing over
the discovery of Ciri's Elven descent.
They'd kill her if they knew.
It's a prophecy.
Maybe it's not true.
[Duny] It doesn't matter if it's true.
It only matters if the people believe it.
And Duny was right because Triss is truly
terrified after what she sees in Ciri, and
reports the matter back to the Brotherhood
at Aretuza who by the end of the season decide
to place a bounty on Ciri and anyone protecting
her.
And talking of Duny, the big twist reveal
at the end is that Ciri's father is still
alive and is actually Emperor Emhyr, aka the
White Flame.
In fact, there was a little hint in Ciri's
dreamworld that her father was still alive,
because notice how everyone from Mousesack
to Calanthe and Pavetta fade away to dust,
but he doesn't.
In the books, Emhyr was the heir to the Nilfgaardian
throne, until his father was overthrown by
someone known as the Usurpur, who had a sorcerer
curse Emhyr and turn him into a hedgehog-human
hybrid.
Emyhr fled Nilfgaard and ended up going under
the alias Duny, keeping his original identity
a secret even after he married Pavetta.
Ciri and her family had assumed Duny died
on the sea voyage he took with his wife;
however, there's a secret reason why he survived
which will take us into likely Season 3 spoiler
territory so you can skip forward to this
timestamp in case you don't want to know yet.
In the books, Duny planned to use the sea
voyage as a way to secretly disappear with
Pavetta and Ciri to Nilfgaard, by faking their
death at sea with the assistance of the mage
Vilgefortz.
However, when Pavetta discovered the plan,
she decided to get Ciri off the boat before
it set sail.
This led to an argument later at sea where
Duny accidentally pushed Pavetta overboard
where she drowned.
Vilgefortz then ported Duny and himself off
the boat which led everyone to assume Duny
had also died on the trip.
In the meantime, Duny returned to reclaim
his position as Emperor of Nilfgaard as well
as his former name Emhyr.
Another twist Emhyr reveals is that he was
the one who ordered the murder of Francesca's
Elven baby, which meant he knew Cahir and
Fringilla were lying to him;
so they end up carted off by Nilfgaardian
soldiers.
Having the baby killed sends Francesca and
the elves north to Nilfgaard's enemy, Redania,
who they believe are to blame for the baby's
death, and Francesca carries out some infanticide
of her own as she casts a spell killing all
Redania's babies.
Francesca also later discovers from Istredd
that Ciri is Hen Ikeir, the Elven term for
Elder Blood, which means the Elves too now
will be looking for the princess in Season
3 as they will see her as a possible saviour
who can liberate them from human persecution.
And lurking in the background of this moment
and many others in Season 2 is Dijkstra's
spy owl, who is finally revealed as Philippa
at the very end.
I'm saying word is out about the girl.
Things just got more fun, Philippa.
Philippa is a sorceress in the Redanian court
with the ability to polymorph into an owl.
Notice also the owl feathers on her costume
and the talon-shaped ring on her hand.
Although Vizimir is the king in Redania, it
seems like Dijkstra together with Philippa
are the ones really pulling the strings in
the kingdom, given Vizimir's overall apathetic
attitude to important matters.
Speaking of which, I'm starving, Dijkstra.
Get to the point.
But there's still another twist to reveal
when Dijkstra tells Philippa:
Bring me the bard.
It's about time he paid back his benefactor.
Dijkstra doesn't mention Jaskier by name,
but it's heavily implied that the famous bard
loved and hated by Geralt, appears to be on
the Redanian payroll.
This is surprising as I didn't detect any
real hints of an alternate agenda during Jaskier's
scenes in Season 2 and my best guess is that
his fame with his "Toss A Coin To Your Witcher"
song put him on Dijkstra's radar as someone
who could potentially spy on the witchers.
That, or there'll be a new bard who's revealed
as a spy in Season 3.
Another pair of characters with their own
agenda are Rience and Lydia.
Rience was initially in jail for crimes during
Calanthe's reign, but when Nilfgaard took
over the city, Lydia came to him with an offer
of freedom in return for hunting down Ciri.
During this mission, he ended up getting half
his face burned by Yennefer, an interesting
change from the books which I explain in my
easter eggs and things you missed video.
Rience managed to steal the vial of Ciri's
blood from Kaer Morhen which he took to Lydia
who attempted to perform blood tracing on
the sample.
This went badly for her, as we discover in
the finale, where we see she suffered significant
injuries from the experiment that burned off
part of her face and now she can only communicate
telepathically.
I won't let you down again, my lord…
As for whom Rience and Lydia are talking to,
I suspect strongly in Season 3 it'll be revealed
to be Vilgefortz.
In the books, Lydia is the mage's personal
assistant and secretary, and there are clues
in the show that Vilgefortz has a hidden agenda.
At the end of the first season, he decided
to murder a Northern solider even though he'd
gone with the rest of the Brotherhood to Sodden
to defend the North against the Nilfgaardian
attack.
And in Season 2, he begins to act strangely
around Tissaia whenever the subject of Ciri
comes up and he seems to be obsessed with
trying to uncover what Tissaia might be hiding
about the princess.
I wouldn't ask you to if it wasn't necessary!
I expect in Season 3, now that Emhyr's identity
as Ciri's father has been revealed, Vilgefortz's
true intentions and what he's getting in return
from the Emperor will also be disclosed.
I'm looking forward to seeing more of the
Redanian Intelligence network and Philippa's
owl spy next season;
however, in real life, you might be troubled
to know that your own internet service provider
may be spying on you and logging all your
online activity.
Which is why I want to thank the sponsor of
this video NordVPN who offer one of the world's
best virtual private networks.
Like the Witcher's powerful Quen sign that
protects against evil forces, a VPN protects
your privacy by encrypting your internet connection
and preventing your internet service provider,
the government, or snoopers from knowing what
websites you're visiting and from reading
your private messages.
And it's also a powerful tool that can help
you bypass geo-location blocks so that you
can access content not available to view or
censored in your country.
Just pick a server in another location and
browse the internet as if you were there.
Something we especially like about Nord is
the super-fast download speeds on its 5,000-plus
servers and how it uses new-generation VPN
technologies like Wireguard.
You can connect up to six devices at the same
time, including your laptop, tablet, desktop,
phone and home router so you can cover all
of your connected devices.
And with our exclusive holiday offer, you
can get a huge 73% off a two-year plan plus
one month free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/FLICKS or tap the link
in the video description to access the offer.
Or use coupon code FLICKS when you check out.
So what do you think about The Witcher's second
season?
And do you have any theories for Season 3?
Let me know in the comments below and if you
enjoyed this then do leave a thumbs-up, I
really appreciate it.
Next tap left to discover all the easter eggs
and crazy details you might have missed in
Season 2.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!